há duas semanas eu estava fazendo uma
exibição dos meus chutes mortais na
cozinha de casa
de vestido longo
tudo bem tudo errado e aí me vi no chão
e quase precisei operar o pé e colocar
os pinos aqui de platina
mas graças a deus não precisa e não só
com essa botinha fashion e cá estou de
pé direito neste palco de honra é mais
para cada ação existe uma reação não é e
para cada reação também uma reflexão e
esse incidente me levou a refletir e é
isso que o homem conteúdo
eu me vi aqui e refletir sobre isso
ele forma o conteúdo sempre terá uma
relação de interdependência de
interpenetração para cada forma haverá
sempre muitos conteúdos tantos quantos
forem os intérpretes tantos quantos
forem as capacidades de interpretar os
seus repertórios e esse é o grande
barato de comunicar as crianças no
processo de comunicar elas não faria
sentido nenhuma teoria nenhuma reflexão
se eu não as inserir-se no processo
por isso no recontando existe um
conselho editorial mirim
as crianças participam da avaliação do
conteúdo
eu saí das redações é criei uma
metodologia de recontar notícias para a
criança foi para o mundo virtual e do
mundo virtual foi para uma sala de aula
e aí a minha apresentação
vamos receber a jornalista simone
monzani que dará em missões oficiais
conteúdo transmídia do recontando
imagina aquele silêncio
continuem assim à pergunta quem é que
gosta da notícia depois do grilo da
professora da pergunta da professora foi
possível ouvir a oposição da música né
amanhã o silêncio daquelas criadas mas o
silêncio foi quebrado
tamanha falta de empatia das crianças
com as notícias
é muito difícil de entender achou o gol
do sport na área jornada sai da sala
não dá pra entender as coisas direita
a notícia é muito chato e z convicta de
que estava diante de legítimos de
nativos digitais
ok meninos e meninas então hoje eu vou
lhes contar a história de uma notícia
a história da notícia da tragédia da
boate 15
lá no rio grande do sul num relance como
se ele tivesse puxado mais familiar dos
assuntos eles se lançaram ao debate a
essa eu já vi essa notícia ser algumas
coisas eu vou operar de uma entrevista
no carro eu vi as fotos no jornal no pai
um vídeo na internet
eles não sabiam mas ele já tinha
uma relação direta uma interação com as
notícias e tem mesmo
ele estava ali revelados os nativos
digitais
a geração z essas crianças super
expostas a todo tipo de informação
eu exibir o vídeo animação
fiz a proposta das brincadeiras e eles
interagiram bem gostaram de ver o
principal ali não foi focar na tragédia
foi a tragédia foi ponto de partida mas
o principal foi re contar como tudo
aconteceu toda a dinâmica do do
incidente
mostrar a importância da observação das
normas de segurança em qualquer lugar
público né que as crianças possam estar
visitando seus pais no dia a dia ea
diferença entre a dinâmica de incêndio
certa vez
participante de uma mesa redonda é sobre
mídia e educação eu fui questionada se
eu não achava houve uma estradinha o
erário público entrando em bolsas e
cuecas dos políticos como no episódio
das manifestações de junho de 2013
naquele momento o momento eu me lembrei
de quando eu parei pra estudar
ainda dentro da minha especialização no
formato das recontratações e me lembrei
do momento quando me deparei com uma
frase emblemática de um escritor inglês
gilbert chesterton nem sonhava com a
atual era midiática abre aspas
os contos de fadas não contam as
crianças que os dragões existem os
contos de fadas contam as crianças que
os dragões podem ser mortas cajá judas é
isso
as crianças são valentes são curiosas
por essência ela já sabem que os dragões
existem
ok você quiser optar
uma bolha em colocar as crianças dentro
de uma bolha pode fazê lo mas certamente
lá também vai pegar wifi
a primeira vez que eu contei uma notícia
para o meu filho e tinha quatro anos
naquele engarrafamento foi quando nasceu
a idéia do recontando o plaza shopping
foi interditado há poucos minutos por
conta de um incêndio em um dos seis
andares de estacionamento segundo o
corpo de bombeiros de niterói ainda não
há vítimas confirmadas o estabelecimento
comercial ficará fechado até que a
equipe dos bombeiros e da perícia
finaliza seus trabalhos
o engarrafamento eu henrique
a notícia mas sim um fator principal a
ele o fator desencadeador um presente de
natal
henrique já tinha escolhido a loja o
presidente
mas a loja do shopping tava interditada
portanto não rolou
a gente não chegou lá e os primeiros
informes que chegava pelo rádio não
foram suficientes
ele começou a interagir com aquelas
notícias com aquelas informações e
começou a querer saber mais
ele queria saber sobre o trabalho dos
bombeiros sobre o trabalho da perícia
sobre o processo da perícia como se o
qual há previsão de reabertura
é o porquê da interdição ou seja toda
apuração que estaria no dia seguinte no
jornal
o que eu fiz no dia seguinte comprei um
jornal eu contei a notícia em detalhes
para ele um ano diante henrique precisou
fazer uma pesquisa para a escola no
doutor das das buscas na web ele lançou
o nome da fruta em questão
o fato real está aposentado ele me
chamou a atenção ao monitor mamãe porque
tem essa moça de biquíni aparecendo aqui
no meio das minhas futuras e ali foi o
momento de falar
explicar pra ele como os valores aos
valores estão diversas misturados hoje
em dia as resignificações né
quando eu era pequena eu era obesa
sofri um bocado com os apelidos maldosos
e chegou um ponto no primeiro quando eu
saí da escola do 1º ciclo e resolvi dar
um basta na tela chatice
resolvi ser a melhor língua portuguesa e
ganhar as olimpíadas
comemorei com tortinha de morango com a
medalha a tortinha ou come a medalha
guardei
mas o principal eu guardei que foi a
experiência de poder resignificar aquela
experiência ruim uma experiência boa uma
nova questão o que eu quero dizer com
isso é que crianças ressignificam
significado significa só o tempo todo
desde sempre e que é bobagem a gente
achar que não existe relação das
notícias com outras questões como por
exemplo temas transversais ciências
matemática física será nesse sentido
no episódio da recomendação da enchente
de xerém e fica lá na baixada fluminense
no rio de janeiro
as crianças de lá do rio de janeiro e de
todos os outros lugares puderam entender
a importância das matas ciliares o
processo de formação da chuva
o cuidado que a gente precisa ter com
lixo
o processo de ocupação irregular das
encostas e o problema do mau uso da
política para a vida das populações
transversalidade está aí né intensa com
jornalismo
desde que o mundo é mundo as histórias
são contadas né
antes em torno das fogueiras e hoje em
todos os lugares e todos eles
convergindo para web aldeia global de
marshall mcluhan está aí
senhoras e senhores a necessidade água
do diálogo é autêntica correria das
crianças
perguntem nada impossível de contar tudo
é possível de recontar op entende não
pode fato de ontem
muito obrigada